[Musique]
illustrator prolifique djibril fall
morissette a dessiné des super héros
pour entre autres marvel mais avec
l'aide de sa soeur il a dessiné des
héroïnes de l'ombre sa grand-mère et sa
mère toutes deux nées au vietnam
on est allé au vietnam qui on a
rencontré les membres de notre famille
on est allé en californie pour
rencontrer des membres de notre famille
qui se sont installés là-bas la bande
dessinée tum terre maternelle commence
en 1945
tout juste avant la guerre d'indochine
la jeune kim mendient au marché
un jour elle décide de vendre son petit
frère le premier épisode de la bd
raconte comme ma grand mère était tout
jeune avec quoi 15 ans je pense 12 ans
puis elle a vendu son petit frère ou
marché en fait conduire parce que parce
que la famine frappe et puis elle avait
faim puis à l'école on peut réfléchir
vraiment que sa mère serait fâché de
cette décision au tournant des années 80
kim
devenu adulte n'a plus rien à perdre
elle donne donc trois onces d'or pour
que ses deux aînés qui est
clandestinement le pays
ma mère et son plus jeune frère elle
avait 15 ans aux femmes avec la table
sont partis dans un bateau clandestin
qui sont restés en mer pendant cinq
jours ils ont fini par accoster en
indonésie pour aller sur les dégâts
langue dans un camp de réfugiés pendant
trois mois moi ce qui me révolte le plus
c'est le plus intimement c'est pas c'est
parce que ma mère spécialement vécu mais
c'est de savoir à quel point ce cas
mamadou b tu sais c'est similaire à ce
que plein de monde vivent actuellement
aujourd'hui jibril et yasmin sont de
fiers montréalais d'origine vietnamienne
et en tant qu immigrants de deuxième
génération
ils sentent le besoin de prendre la
parole pour tous ceux et celles qui ne
le font pas on eu cette responsabilité
là comme deuxième génération de
d'abord une une vue sur les conséquences
de l'intégration les difficultés de la
chose après cette première saga
familiale
le frère et la soeur travaille sur une
suite qui pourrait raconter l'histoire
de leur père ouais bon ici louvier
depuis mai radio-canada moria